welcome back in this week's you learn to
implement a neural network before diving
into the technical details I wanted in
this video to give you a quick overview
of what you'll be seeing in this week's
videos so if you don't follow all the
details in this video don't worry about
it we'll delve in the technical details
in the next few videos but for now let's
give a quick overview of how you
implement in your network last week we
had talked about logistic regression and
we saw how this model corresponds to the
following computation graph where you
didn't put the features X and parameters
W MB does allows you to compute Z which
is then used to compute a and we were
using a interchangeably with this output
Y hat and then you can compute the loss
function l a new network looks like this
and as I already previously alluded you
can form a neural network by stacking
together a lot of little sigmoid units
whereas previously this node corresponds
to two steps of calculations the first
three compute the Z value second is it
computes this a value in this doing
network this stack of notes will
correspond to a Z like calculation like
this as well as an a like calculation
like that and then that node will
correspond to another Z and another 8
like calculation so the notation which
we should use later will look like this
first what inputs the features X
together with some parameters W and B
and this will allow you to compute z1 so
new notation that one should use is that
we'll use superscript square bracket 1
to refer to quantities associated with
this stack of node is called a lair and
then later we'll use superscript square
bracket 2 to refer to quantities
associated with Daniel really that's
called another layer of the network and
the superscript square brackets like we
have here are not to be confused with
the superscript round brackets which we
used to refer to individual training
examples so whereas
X superscript on racket I refer to the
I've trained example superscript square
bracket 1 and 2 refer to these different
um layers layer 1 and layer 2 in this
network but they're going on after
computing z1 similar to logistic
regression there'll be a computation to
compute a 1 and that's just some sigmoid
of z1 and then you compute Z 2 using
another linear equation and then compute
a 2 and a 2 is the final output of the
neural network and will also be used
interchangeably with Y hat so I know
that was a lot of details but the key
intuition to take away is that whereas
for logistic regression we had this Z
followed by a calculation and this new
network here we just do it multiple
times as Z followed by a calculation and
a Z qualifying a calculation and then
you finally compute the loss and yet and
you remember that for logistic
regression we had in some backward
calculation in order to compute
derivatives are so confusing
da easy and so on so in the same way a
new network will end up doing a backward
calculation that looks like this it will
jump you end up computing da 2 DZ 2 that
allows you to compute
DW 2 DB 2 and so on in this sort of a
right to left backward calculation that
is denoting with the red arrows so thank
you
quick overview of what a neural network
website space you take the logistic
regression and repeating it twice I know
there's a lot of new notation love new
details don't worry about they didn't
follow everything we'll go into the
details most slowly in the next few
videos so let's go on to the next video
we'll stop to talk about the neural
network representation